So, I danced to this new song, that I don't know if you all know about this "Gangnam Style"...
...but this video is blowing up all over the place, and you tweeted out about it.
Right?
Yes!
Alright, if you haven't seen it, let's just show them a little bit of this video, of how great this guy is.
It's brilliant.
He's fantastic, isn't he?
Yes.
Amazing!
Alright!
So, you actually tweeted out that you wanna learn that dance, right?
Yes.
Alright, so I got somebody here to teach you that dance.
Oh!
Psy, come on out!
Oh my god!
Nice to see you.
Fantastic!
Alright!
Go on!
Show me!
It looks easier than it is, but it's like a two and then one, right?
How do you do it?
You have to take your shoes off; you're not gonna be able to dance like that.
This is fine because the mindset of this dance is to dress classy and dance cheesy, so there's a trend there.
This is nice.
Alright.
And by the way, can I introduce myself?
Yes, please do.
Not just dancing?
Okay.
I'm Psy from Korea, how are you?
Psy from Korea!
We love you!
Oh, really?
We love you. You are amazing!
Alright.
Alright, so it goes like, one, and two, and three, and four.
One, and two, and three, and four.
Why don't you try?
And your hands have gotta be soft like this, and bounce like you're riding an invisible horse.
Bounce like this, and then it goes like this.
Alright. Theme of the music. One, two, three, four!
Okay.
That is Psy!